it was a huge week for the the Supreme
Court and the gays as we call them now
DOMA was struck down prop 8 is going
back to the states so a lot of good
stuff happens for marriage equality and
it got me thinking about how television
and media influences our ability to
change in how it affects society and
then it had me thinking particularly
about one clip from my favorite all-time
show The Golden Girls
about marriage equality this so this is
a Golden Girls clip I believe this is
season 7 1992 take a look Blanche I've
been thinking about Clayton and Doug and
I have a question what why do men have
nipples
I have no idea you think it's because
God has a sense of humor and this and
this uptight is the rest of us it's
easier for you to say that Sophie it's
not your brother who's getting married
to a man oh look I can accept the fact
that he's gay but why does he have to
slip a ring on this guy's fingers or the
whole world will know why did you marry
George we loved each other we wanted to
make a lifetime commitment wanted
everybody to know that's what Doug and
Clayton want to
everyone wants someone to grow old with
and shouldn't everyone have that chance
it's a fear I think I see what you're
getting there I don't think you do
Blanche will you marry me
Thank You sensei
I need to go talk to them fine but I'll
need an answer I'm not gonna wait for
you forever all right I love that clip
for so many reasons first off funny
funny funny and also it was telling
truth and again this is 20-some odd
years ago and they were telling and this
was in Florida gay marriage certainly
wasn't legal 22 years ago far that's not
legal now so I think this brings us to
an interesting topic which is how much
does this stuff actually translates way
into reality because on one hand you can
look at this and go well that's amazing
they did that 22 years ago but it took
it still took 22 years to get this far
so should we be inspired by these these
things that come out of pop culture I
think so I think it's an important part
of the process I think when we fall in
love with characters and we feel like
they're our own family our own friends
then after that investment when we see
we're so much more likely to hear what
they have to say when it's as funny and
wonderful as that and I think I think so
much did lead up to it I think Will and
Grace played a big role you know in the
early 2000s I think there were a lot of
shows the more it was represented on our
television sets the more I think the
country was able to empathize and
understand and get on board and I think
I it's it's a kind of a nice thing for
you know the comedy I mean obviously I
think it was fantastic it it talked
about a topic that wasn't really talked
about on television this is before when
grace before Modern Family our new
normal or any of these shows were in our
living rooms where we were normal
already cancelled right Wow yeah
positive you know gay role models on
television that people could you know
really get behind and I love that the
Sophia who is the oldest you know Sicily
picture at 1910 you know it's like she's
educating the younger generation if
anything you would think she would be
the one that needed to be you know
educated so I love that
but yeah it's like you said I mean it's
any time that we see other people doing
anything I mean
opinion it always always always has an
effect on you because it makes you think
well what would I do or what would I you
know see or what would I think well I
think okay so I'm with you guys 100% so
far and stuff like that has a huge
powerful impactful you know society Amon
Terry however is there is this a bit of
a slippery slope because like when all
these politicians jump on TV and they
always say well there's too much gun
violence and TV and in videogames and
that's why people are shooting each
other so does it run both ways that we
get good images that are changes for the
good but bad images the changes from Ed
I'm not a personal believer that video
games cause violence because otherwise
I'd be an Italian plumber eating
mushrooms jumping on Turtles but you
noted me like does dude does it go both
ways if the good stuff is good for us is
the bad stuff equally as bad I think
it's easy to say that yeah absolutely
you gotta take you know you gotta take
your sugar with your with your salt and
if you're gonna stand on one side you
got kind of got to stand on it you know
for both sides but I think part of it
and this is the point that I totally
completely I'm just killing time thank
you I appreciate that is I think in 1992
I think there was still a lot of people
who hadn't come out yet and so I think
there was a lot of areas of the world
but certainly even just our nation where
people didn't really know that many gay
people not that they maybe didn't know
that they were gay or maybe it wasn't
accepted and so showing it on television
is like showing them it's like they know
somebody I know cam you know even if in
their personal life they don't know
somebody you know who's gay or who's out
there like oh that's so cool and that
builds you know tolerance and all of
that but you're right I don't think look
I think environment has a little bit to
do with why people do things absolutely
I mean this guy that went in like he was
the Joker in Batman and shot up that I
mean do I think that he would have gone
that route if he hadn't seen the Dark
Knight I don't know he probably had a
screw loose to begin with right I might
have just done it a different way
without a joker mask it has no influence
no I have to say that I really do think
it does have an influence but I think
you have to be smart enough to be like
okay this is a game this is a movie this
is not real or whatever it is and
hopefully when it's something positive
like you know tolerance people are like
this is cool yeah did you guys have any
shows that affected you in any specific
way anything that maybe empowered you as
women or as comic personalities or
whatever it might be
sure listen mix matching my socks every
day because of punky no yeah like you
know blossom and now we're going to
address I don't know if any of them
spoke to me personally but it was as a
kid you know you're hearing about all
these things that you are maybe
sheltered from and don't know about and
and therefore are enlightened by that
very special episode yeah I remember a
very special episode of growing pains
when they go to you know Kirk Cameron
Mike Seaver goes to a party with Boehner
I don't have that name that could pose
like something that was in a media the
word name is guy born but you know and
Boehner goes off and does coke with you
know a bunch of other kids and my cousin
and they made it a very special and that
stuff does hit with you as a kid right
absolutely and that's a lot easier way
to do it than just like on the news or
somebody like pushing it down your
throat it's like they kind of put it in
entertainment and make it softer and
especially with Golden Girls I mean that
was a sitcom they made it funny they
made it light-hearted it wasn't
something that was like tragic or or
hushed or anything like that so kudos to
them I think for the Golden Girls thank
you for being a friend I've had to say
it we believe once in this segment